the White House is taking its first
steps to punish those involved in the
murder of Washington Post contributor
Jamal khashoggi President Trump who
accepted the original Saudi denials of
responsibility now says Khashoggi 'he's
killing involved quote the worst
cover-up in history Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo said the State Department
will revoke visas for 21 Saudis the US
has identified as being involved in the
operation Holly Williams is in Istanbul
where khashoggi was killed in Saudi
Arabia's consulate Holly good morning
good morning we're expecting to hear
from Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
today at an investment conference in
Saudi Arabia it will be his first speech
since the killing of Jamal hisagi here
at the Saudi consulate in Istanbul in
which some believe the prince was
culpable Saudi Arabia is scrambling to
carry out damage control extraordinary
pictures in Saudi media showed the king
and Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
delivering their personal condolences
to Jamal has shock geez grieving brother
and son yesterday we can only imagine
their feelings about the meeting since
many believed the crown prince was
somehow involved in her shock geez
killing president Trump again stressed
the importance of the us-saudi
relationship yesterday but he also
sharply criticized the killing of her
Shoji and the Saudi deception that
followed the cover up was horrible the
execution was horrible but they should
have never been at an execution or a
cover-up because it should have never
happened when Mohammed bin Salman made
his first appearance at the investment
conference yesterday he was greeted with
applause the crown prince has portrayed
himself as a moderniser
and the conference is supposed to
showcase his reforms but at least two
dozen business and political leaders
have pulled out in protest over his Shah
jees slaying there's still no official
word on what the Saudis did with her
Shoji's body in Istanbul yesterday
police searched a car abandoned in an
underground parking lot and registered
to the Saudi consulate
but Turkish media is reporting they've
found no significant evidence linking it
to her shabti turkish President Recep
Tayyip Erdogan stressed again today that
Turkey will not allow a cover-up over
Jamal Hodges death
bianna he has been defiant Holly
Williams in Istanbul thank you